hey youtubers it's Charlie welcome back
to my game of thrones season for
countdown so for this video I wanted to
talk all about the big game of thrones
marathon that's happening this weekend
as well as some alternatives in case you
don't have access to HBO and you don't
want to ask your friend for their HBO Go
password but seriously if they're
willing to give it to you they deserve a
giant high-five for the rest of us
though there's a ton of other stuff we
can do between rereading some of the
most important chapters leading up to
what's going to be happening in episode
1 as well as playing some of the you
know tabletop games I'll be talking
about that there's a special event
happening later this weekend and to add
to all that george RR martin just posted
an aria wins a winter chapter to his
website he just replaced the Martell
chapter basically if you're finding me
for the first time and you're all like
WTF Game of Thrones countdown I'm just
doing a special you know video countdown
series to get everyone ready get pumped
up back into dragon mode before episode
1 airs on Sunday be sure to subscribe to
get everything i'll have details about
what my you know videos will look like
when the season starts at the end of
this video so first let's talk about
that big marathon if you have access to
HBO they'll be doing a 60 hour marathon
starting on Friday they're just airing
everything from Season one to season
three back-to-back twice that last
episode will air just before season 4
episode 1 so you could potentially lock
yourself in a room and do nothing but
watch it all weekend I would not advise
doing that but let me know if you try
for people who don't have access to HBO
or if you just don't feel like we're
watching everything there's the books in
all the expanded material for Danny you
should start with Storm of Swords
chapter 42 that ends basically where
season 3 ended you know up to the events
where season 3 ended if you want to
preview of what's going to be happening
in episode 1 you know you can skip
forward to chapter 57 thankfully most of
her story at least for the first part of
this season is going to be contained a
book 3 so you won't need to read into
book four or five for all the King's
Landing people it's a little bit
trickier just because Jamie came back
sooner than he did in the books with the
exception of him pretty much everything
you need to reread is also in book 3 i
would actually use Tyrians chapters as a
guide starting with chapter 53 if you
want to reread the red wedding chapter
and what follows go all the way back to
chapter 49 lots of reading I know so
basically if you don't
want any spoilery stuff just reread
storm sores chapter 42 253 you can read
53 but don't go past that because there
is a John chapter with some spoilery
stuff after that if you don't want to
reread anything then i would actually
advise going out and checking out the
card game or some of the cool 3d puzzles
because they're actually really awesome
i'm actually going to geek & sundry
tabletop day on Saturday this Saturday
that is so I'm hoping to find some
people to play the card game there if
you live in Los Angeles I think there's
still tickets available they include hot
dogs and beer which is awesome you have
to be over 13 to get in though you know
because boobs obviously 21 to partake
but there will be tons of games and
here's all my social links i'll be
posting pictures and videos to instagram
and twitter throughout the day for that
i'll also post that tickets link in the
description below in related news i'll
pry a time for about two more bonus
videos before episode 1 airs on Sunday
so let me know in the comments what you
want to see in those so a lot of people
have actually reached out to me to about
the giveaway that i'll be doing because
I'll be doing my review video on Sunday
and my Q&A video on Monday just like
walking de videos but since a lot of you
in international countries said that you
don't get to watch the episodes till a
day after I'm gonna try and rethink the
way that works so that you guys can
participate too so I might be doing
another bonus video on Tuesday but be
sure to let me know when game of thrones
airs in your country so I can figure all
that out thank you very much for that
right now click here to watch all my
other countdown videos and click here to
watch the last trailer thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you